aujourd'hui on se trouve sur défaut d'un
jeu de plates-formes sauf qu'en fait ces
mecs qui ont créé le jeu sont partis du
principe que ils ont voulu un peu changé
toutes les règles d'un jeu de falletans
vous allez voir monsieur la tortue avec
dan l'homme bizarre s'amuse une
princesse de deux centimètres et demi
les voit danser et si affaires lachine
bombes sur eux en disant non c'est pas
permis
car abondance et alors ferme l'autre qui
dansent aussi à m'arrêter dans c'est
quoi un jour ok elle le prend dans son
petit nuage
elle rigole de manière pointue
diabolique à samba et dames s'en bat les
couilles il coutume dans ses annonces
mon copain de sa fille kidnappée
mais comment vais-je faire ok ça marche
mais la violence du truc quoi je pense
qu'en fait tu comprends les pièces ne
personne meurt c'est ça voilà voilà jeté
au sein d'airbus tout ça regroupe monde
dans l'aube rouge verte
non mais attends et acheter en glucides
quoi et oh ok d'accord vous bien ok moi
dit il fallait bien les ramasseurs
puisqu'il y avait un conteur au bras
gauche et à sa trotteuse le cerveau
c'est juste horrible c'est un long
chemin en dessous utilise sa plateforme
alors des petits la plateforme mais
[ __ ] mon gars c'est quoi encore cette
propagande totalement fausse a bafoué se
laisser tomber
bien sûr va faire une partie de mario à
fabien jouent à je crois moi tu vas
faire le score le plus nul d'avis mais
comment on prend cette courte tête à
voile à attend est ce que les drapeaux
du coup ne sont pas non c'est bon je
suis défaut d'années je vais sauver le
monde
ok ont bondi sur les picards
mais pourquoi pourquoi les couples
explosent s'il faut les ramasser
j'ai c'est que ça faut aller dessus je
suis sûr mais dans mes mails oui c'est
un gâteau mine pour laver tous reconnu
le fameux gâteau mine de terminator 4
si je fais ça l'idée de merde au fatah
son aspect doux et délicieux en fait
c'est un dangereux psychopathe qui se
cache dans ce pub un gros problème des
faux dan et change de style [ __ ] up
okello adams taille version à boffa on
réessaie ou pas des sûr que non tu
ferais mieux de commencer en courant ça
me va aux bâtards au le passage sans je
sens la connerie j'aime bien ça fait
plaisir j'ai envie de passer toute la
vidéo a sauté sur ses piques ceci est la
seule pièce collectables est ce que tu
vas vraiment à la récupérer ok ça se
trouve ya une coupe cacher non mais
c'est évident ce pouvait pas être autre
chose que ça va du coup non j'ai pas
reprendre la pièce et non [ __ ] [ __ ]
j'ai mangé trois il fait quoi lui dois
tout ce dont tu as besoin c'est de
l'amour on tape trop la violence
j'ai pas besoin de marcher sur la tête
d'un monsieur qui a une coupe au bol
pour passer voilà je refuse je m'en vais
je ne sens pas eu tout ce nuage qui
auraient l'idée de monter sur ce nuage
avec la seule chose qu'il a envie de
faire cet te faire du mal sans déconner
regardez-moi ça là allez maintenant je
veux ma coupe et je les y être un [ __ ]
ça j'ai oublié keskia on n'a pas le
droit de prendre des pièces je suis un
grand père moi et c'est quoi ça c'est
monsieur patate
monsieur patate avec un bob sur la tête
en fait ouais mais skient qu'est ce qui
a jamais eu de copine dans ma vie avons
fait rien si j'ai une copine tu vas voir
j'ai absolue de superman vont en
quelques secondes en fait pas du tout et
je suis un gros ton avec une casquette
rouge et un polo moche je sais je sais
qu'elle est vilaine mais comment je fais
keep moving to stay alive à aulnoye
jouent pas le jeu sur la présidence de
foued scandaleux merde on a zéro étoile
on est morts 15 fois et on n'a qu'une
coupe hutin on déchire trois jeux quoi
c'est qu'une démo a donc bien évidemment
il ya cinq niveaux
alors je vois juste de place à l'écran
je collecte corns calais ce jeu de satik
[ __ ] ok en fait ce petit morceau
demain l'ambassade pour toutes les
pièces high five la main non battant
woods a fait une fournée de gâteaux là
en fait elle m'énerve à m à chaque fois
que j'y suis allé à l'estate hathaway
les gâteaux surprise et pas dans mon
gars à temps mais qui tue j'ai fait on
arrive enfin
non mais attends mais là c'est que
quelques landes quoique que je fais
comment attention le punch de dan
je mets des enfants royaux nom est alors
lui on fait comment on peux moi oui mais
lyon peut monter sur lui regardez c'est
monsieur patate avec un voile sur la
tête et des ailes on dirait plutôt des
gants artigues en plastique au plat ou
plat je passe comment là ya pas une
potion pour devenir plus petits mais que
ses couleurs il porter haut la pièce au
passage qu'il suit sa coque quelques
maires défaut dernièrement de rambo nous
sommes plus qu'heureux gentil non vous
êtes méchant oui je tu estimes tu me
fait pas peur au revoir car non non non
non non non on s'est dit au revoir c'est
le style de défauts date va doucement tu
vas y arriver
oui bah jazz déjà tu veux pas d'ordre
aux [ __ ] mais qd je ne peux pas
passer par où je passerai pas en bas non
mais attends je les paye
mais j'explose mais un ca de la coupe
quoi suffirait juste qu'un petit orteil
viennent comme ça et face aux pelotes au
hall express de gros bâtards ils ont dit
va lentement et ça va le faire en fait
faut courir pour passer ça non mais je
déteste les pièces au nom plus tard ok
le coeur leur tour et revient vers moi
dangereusement va s'en aller vite faire
alenya jeté un verre pas le nuage
pervers hawaï qui me fait enfin plaisir
[ __ ] oh non non non le retour des
cupcakes ménard les pétales gâteau ça
faisait longtemps que j'ai pas joué un
jeu un petit jouera j'en ai ma foi cela
fait tout cas pas mal tu pourrais
acheter quelque chose de cool avec
toutes ces pièces ne me tente pas je
résisterai à la tentation
maintenant tu es super enfantin j'ai
besoin de jouer à la démo mais en
version tient fdp et a eu 7 sur 20 à
l'école punition j'y crois pas quoi mais
ce choeur est tellement mais voilà j'ai
la maladie du spa sauna menace émane a
mais c'était juste en bas pour finir en
fait c'était une coupe à droite
abattant à des coupes en plus elle te
tuer tout faux pas les ramasser week au
plus que deux niveaux et c'est la fin de
la démo on en est là tu passes je
suppose c'est comme les tuyaux
c'est quoi ta aux gars je suis dit hé
et les piques sur mes copains le pic
sommet appuyez sur espace conte sauter
plus haut et fort je me prenne un truc
et je meurs c'est ça que tu verras ben
non mon gars [ __ ] mais pour passer je
suis obligé attention la technique pgm
au plein et là elle nous amène à une
coupe c'est certain pas mal batman b de
la coupe mon gars ok tu le sens voisin
tout secret mais c'était pas très secret
aller tous ensemble trois étoiles 3
coupes qu'une mort de mieux en mieux
c'est l'heure de récupérer au nom
vilaine princesse elle est venue me le
reprendre
elle rigole de manière diabolique où se
mouche dans sa main je ne sais pas trop
l es tu au moins deux mois non mais
[ __ ] mais au fait que je joue en fait
tu sais pas qui obtint j'étais sur un
nuage mais tu t'attardes avec mon gars
attend même quoi mais ça va aussi un
bateau à chercher un nombre de morts
considère ce à quoi la [ __ ] mais je
tiens c'est la leur de la défense et ça
très dur on vit des moments difficiles
tous ensemble c'est très très très très
très très 2 je veux sauver monsieur
tortue et bien sûr la coller une bonne
même si dense quand même que je fais
peut-être pas le sauver c'est pas la
soeur de nan c'est pas pour avoir un
style aussi dire aussi eu public
maintenant je prends mon petit nuage
tatata interne à l'ump car je dis ça je
dis rien oui c'est quoi que les nuages
plaît aux [ __ ] un truc j'ai encore
perdu général j'ai je le prends et je
m'en fous et ils vécurent heureux et les
danseurs jusqu'à la fin de leur vie avec
un feu d'artifice en plein jour et
monsieur tortue pourrait nous faire
plaisir à voir un peu de reconnaissance
non because i'm happy la bellongue ita
gueule obama les gens c'est déjà prendre
cette vidéo sur des faux donne qui est
pour le coup un jeu vraiment original
étant donné qu'ils ont complètement
inversé des codes des jeux de plates
formes ce qui en devient encore plus
rageant la fois j'espère que ça vous
aura plus cette année ce n'est pas de la
vidéo ça favre encaissé le plus évident
qu'une nouvelle vidéo à john moore
[Musique]